Megan first of all you have the perfect
hair for tonight breast cancer were
raising money what does it mean to
perform an event like that is there an
extra element of specialness yeah yeah
when I was putting on this soup today
everyone's like it was like a superhero
and I was like today I get to play one
you know good i-i'll if it's such an
honor being here and all my friends are
backstage and we're just like performing
and having the best night ever and it's
for a great cause so it just makes it
that much better
speaking of music girlfriend I need an
update I know you're still so full of
music I know you're feeling inspired
what's going on I'm on a lot of I'm up
and I'm a featured girl right now which
I'm loving because I get to do a whole
music video and then it's like it's out
and it's me with like new friends I am -
on cliff just got paid segala song with
Ella Eyre and French Montana
[Music]
[Applause]
and then I have a new song coming out
with CNC Oh an amazing Spanish boy group
that I love and chomp up which is like
bucket list dreams for me when does that
come out no but we shot the music video
like a couple days ago and I look like
beautiful like Marilyn Monroe like
old-school classy and yeah it looks
pretty hot I check it out
[Music]
in theme with a song just got paid what
is your most outrageous splurge since
making it my business manager tells me
like I don't spend a lot of money which
is tight right but I spend all my money
on Amazon and I did the one thing I'd
like I'm gonna buy this for myself I'm
gonna do it was my Tesla cart yeah I
didn't care the environment I'm helping
the world yeah we're here today are you
getting married this holiday season is
that happening I think so yeah I'm not
supposed to say anything but I'm
definitely gonna get married soon he
said yes to the dress
no one have it but I said yes so a lot
of things for pictures what are you
thinking princess ask everything inside
thinking like definitely a cape I don't
know why I've never won a game ever but
I'm thinking like the big gown I don't
know have you done the cake testing and
stuff show my curves no I have not gone
that I'm gonna be lots of do my stylist
said I was like can we talk I was like
okay
[Music]